[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse c'est Monsieur le Ministre des
Solidarités et de la santé ce week-end
j'étais à Breteuil une charmante ville
de matières conscription à Breteuil il y
a une maison de santé intégrée au
patrimoine local comme souvent les élus
locaux se démènent pour trouver une
solution de proximité afin de pallier au
désert médicaux un mal de l'Oise pour ne
pas dire un mal français une
pharmacienne de Breteuil est venue me
voir d'une voie tremblante mais sûre où
l'inquiétude se mêlait à la colère elle
n'avait pas reçu ses cartons de
médicaments pourtant commander il y a
quelques semaines avec le désespoir au
fond de la voix elle m'annonce qu'elle
n'a plus de gaviscon d'amoxicilline de
sirop pour la toux et de doliprane
pédiatrique cela se passe en ce moment
même dans le pays de pasteur ce matin
elle m'a encore affirmé que son
fournisseur n'avait plus d'antibiotiques
pédiatriques et plus d'insuline si je
prends cet exemple concret c'est pour
illustrer la réalité du quotidien dans
territoire la France souffre d'une
maladie chronique qui se répand partout
à travers de nombreux produits
essentiels elle s'appelle pénurie
comment expliquer cette absence de
médicaments très largement utilisé pour
combattre aussi les maladies de l'hiver
nos lignes industrielles sont-elles en
train de nous lâcher est-ce un manque
d'anticipation aux pénuries de
médicaments s'ajoutent l'abondance des
rhumes des angines des grippes sans
parler de la bronchiolite et du covid
qui revient les pulls ne suffiront pas
les tensions des stocks auront des
conséquences durables sur la santé de
nos concitoyens vous dites que le
problème sera réglé dans quelques
semaines ou quelques mois pouvez-vous
nous donner monsieur le ministre des
précisions sur l'état des lieux des
pénuries faudrait-il patienter jusqu'en
mars 2023 pour soigner le système
d'approvisionnement comme l'indique
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et en attendant monsieur le
ministre que répondez-vous à cette
pharmacienne désemparée de Breteuil car
à l'heure des fêtes de Noël il est
incongru de penser que le plus beau
cadeaux que l'on puisse faire à des
parents est une boîte de doliprane pour
enfants